herzlich willkommen zu unserer heutigen
corona sprechstunde es geht heute um
einen faktencheck mit einem virologen
wir schauen uns alle möglichen steilen
thesen an die derzeit so im internet
kursieren und die teilweise auch mit
großem erfolg geteilt werden und wir
haben uns gedacht dass beleuchten wir
mal mit einem fachmann und bei diesem
fach mann handelt es sich um dr martin
stürmer er ist biologe leitet ein labor
in frankfurt am main und lehrt auch an
der dortigen johann wolfgang von goethe
universität ist schöner abend herr
stürmer hallo hallo erst mal vielleicht
zunächst einmal die frage nach ihrer
persönlichen situation was unsere
zuschauer noch nicht wissen sie selber
waren auch an cupid 19 erkrankt haben
die krankheit bereits durchgemacht wie
war ihr verlautete krankheitsverlauf und
wie geht es ihnen heute ja verlaufe
erfreulicherweise mild ich bin ja doch
mit 51 jahren und dann bestehenden
bluthochdruck der verwandelt ist nicht
ganz ungefährlich gewesen was einen
schwereren verlauf angeht aber toy story
ist es insgesamt recht mild verlaufen
und ich bin voll wiederhergestellt und
fühle mich eigentlich in keinster weise
durch die erkrankung benachteiligt oder
beeinträchtigt sein dass man so und wir
sind sehr froh dass sie heute abend für
uns zur verfügung stehen und eben dieses
thema mit uns zusammen noch einmal
angehen um was es genau dabei geht um
welche thesen beziehungsweise wogegen
sich auch kritiker zb des aktuellen
politischen handelns auch richten
das zeigt uns jetzt erstmal mein kollege
antoine kurschilgen
dieses bild wird immer mehr zur
normalität in deutschland menschen
tragen schutzmasken in der
öffentlichkeit und es werden immer mehr
denn sie werden dazu gezwungen per
masken pflicht ein bundesland nach dem
anderen zieht nach sachsen sachsen
anhalt thüringen bayern berlin baden
württemberg hamburg hessen schleswig
holstein und mecklenburg vorpommern
es werden immer mehr denn der kampf
gegen korona ist noch lange nicht vorbei
das virus ist nicht weg es ist kein ende
der epidemie in sicht die fallzahlen
können wieder steigen deshalb ist es so
wichtig dass wir trotz der ersten
lockerungen die lage weiterhin sehr
ernst nehmen und sich alle an die
empfehlungen halten
doch es gibt auch die das ganz anders
sehen die kontaktsperre seien sinnlos
die bevölkerung werde an der nase
herumgeführt diese behauptungen
kursieren auf diesem und anderen youtube
kanälen
sie beziehen sich auf diese grafik des
robert-koch-instituts sie zeigt dass die
hre produktionszahl bereits am 21 märz
unter 1 lag also jeder infizierte im
schnitt weniger als eine person
angesteckt hat bei diesem wert ist die
epidemie kontrollierbar zwei tage später
am 23 märz verkündet kanzlerin merkel
den shutdown mit kontakt verboten
sie unterstellen der kanzlerin also
wider besseres wissen gehandelt zu haben
also die eliten müssen um den bürgern
sachverhalt wenn sie es nicht mehr
sparen als bundesgesundheitsminister
ohne was denn mit zwölf zurück ist ja so
verhalten kann man überhaupt nur
erklären er weist das ganze ist ihr mann
wie ihn oder sie verwischt oder mich
überhaupt nicht gefährlich
in wirklichkeit konnten sparen und
merkel das aber gar nicht wissen weil
das robert koch institut die
produktionszahl für den 21 märz erst im
april rückwirkend berechnen konnte das
robert-koch-institut kann zu dem
damaligen zeitpunkt die daten noch gar
nicht gehabt haben das ist ja von anfang
an das problem dass die aktuellen
fallzahlen des robert-koch-instituts der
realität um viele viele tage hätten
wenn ich heute krank werden
bis sich die ersten symptome entwickeln
das dauert im schnitt so sechs tage bis
ich dann einen termin für den test
bekomme bis der test ausgewertet ist vom
labor bis das gesundheitsamt davon
erfährt wird bis das gesundheitsamt dem
robert-koch-institut meldung macht das
dauert bis zu zehn tage dazu die
inkubationszeit also das heißt das
robert-koch-institut hatte diese daten
erst ende märz anfang april der shutdown
sei auch deswegen völlig unnötig gewesen
weil sich die reproduktions zeit danach
nicht wirklich verbessert habe die
kontakt verbote seien also wirkungslos
auch diese behauptung ist mehr als
fraglich
unser gast heute der virologe dr
martin stürmer hersteller waren jetzt
einige punkte dabei die wir gerne der
reihe nach aufgreifen wollen fangen wir
vielleicht gerade mal mit dem ende des
beitrags an der shutdown habe nichts
gebracht sehen sie das auch so
nein das sehe ich im gegenteil ganz
anders gehen wir gerne das beispiel der
der vereinigten staaten an weil dort ist
ja letztendlich lange nichts gemacht
worden hat das virus ja so ein bisschen
verleugnet will ich nicht sagen aber
schon so hinten angestellt oder als
unwichtig erachtet und man sieht ja in
welcher hohen geschwindigkeit die
fallzahlen in die höhe geschossen ist
und wie viele menschen letztendlich in
die krankenhäuser müssen versterben also
nichts zu tun wäre fatal gewesen
insofern ist es genau andersrum die
maßnahmen sind absolut berechtigt ein
punkt der auch in dem beitrag
angesprochenen wurde ist die inzwischen
fast schon berüchtigte re
produktionszahl das wollen wir uns
gerade auch gerne noch mal anschauen
dazu gibt es eben auch eine grafik vom
rkw vom robert-koch-institut wenn man
sich das hier auf der seite anschaut
dann kommt man eben unten zu dieser
kurve die mehr für ihn natürlich auch
aufgefallen ist und die uns vor allem in
der redaktion auch schon aufgefallen ist
die auch in der diskussion ist da geht
es eben um den zeitpunkt an dem diese
reproduktions zahl bereits unter 1 lag
nämlich hier am 23
dritte können sie verstehen dass es da
in der bevölkerung irritationen gibt
oder zumindest die frage danach auf
kommt warum wird denn jetzt so sehr
darauf geachtet wenn jedoch eben schon
länger so ist wie sie ist ja
nachvollziehen kann man das natürlich
weil es gab es geht vielen so die rennen
auf einmal
werte oder begriffe mit dem man bis dato
nichts zu tun hatte dann bekommt man
grafiken bekommt in den medien gesagt
der wert muss unter 1 sein dann ist
alles gut und das problem ist dass es so
einfach eben leider nicht ist
natürlich ist ein wert unter 1 erstmal
von vorteil weil das heißt nichts
anderes als dass ein mensch nicht mehr
automatisch mindestens ein oder mehr
menschen ansteckt sondern dass es
weniger wird das nicht unbedingt jeder
infizierte gleich jemanden anderes
ansteckt und es ist aber auch klar wenn
man diese bedeutung weiß dass so ein
wert mit 0,9 0,8 nicht wirklich weit
unter 1 liegt und weil diese ganze sache
eben auch den schwankungen unterliegt
dann ist das eben auch gefährlich ein
sobald baldiges abfallen unter 1 sofort
als wir haben die pandemie im griff zu
interpretieren diese zahlen muss über
eine sehr viel längeren zeitraum
deutlich unter 1 sein und eben nicht bei
0,9 oder 0,7 sondern eben noch tiefer
damit er wirklich sicher sein können
dass diese pandemie beherrschbar ist
oder sich irgendwann totlaufen wird und
dementsprechend ist auch der vorwurf
falsch das eigentlich mit dem
erstmaligen wert unter 1 23 schon alles
gegessen war das ist definitiv nicht
richtig klare aussage von ihnen wird die
b auf youtube fragt wie soll es zu einer
herdenimmunität kommen wenn menschen
keinen kontakt zueinander haben
das ist richtig das wird so nicht
rechnerisch sehr sehr lange dauern wenn
wir mal überlegen wir haben 2009
infektionen pro tag haben wir rechnen
mit 60 70 prozent die näheren immunität
oder die infiziert sein müssten für die
herren immunität 50 millionen menschen
bei 2.000 pro tag da müssen wir selber
tage warten
insofern ist die frage völlig berechtigt
was wir jetzt hier schaffen wir gewinnen
zeit wir gewinnen zeit in der wir an
impfstoff auf den markt bringen können
der funktionieren wird und der
letztendlich dafür sorgen wird dass
durch die impfung geben an entsprechende
immunität in der bevölkerung an
generiert wird ist natürlich immer so
ein bisschen der blick in die glaskugel
aber von wieviel zeit reden wir da was
glauben sie wie lange braucht die
wissenschaft die forschung dafür ist
schon auf einem sehr sehr guten weg
dahin und ich denke mal dass wir ganz
optimistisch sind
am ende dieses jahres aber sicherlich
anfang nächsten jahres ein impfstoff
haben werden was sich dann natürlich
noch anschließt die frage inwieweit er
denn im prinzip auch in der produktion
her
die breite masse verfügbar gemacht
werden kann auch im beitrag gesehen die
tendenz zu mehr atemschutzmasken dass
wir auch ein thema auf und runter gerade
heute auch in den nachrichten immer mehr
bundesländer fordern oder führen auch
die pflicht die atemschutzmasken pflicht
sozusagen ein wie sehen sie diese
entwicklung ja auch die beobachte ich
kann mich an die anfänge erinnern wo wir
halt gesagt haben die masken sind nicht
notwendig die bilden keinen zusätzlichen
schutz der hände waschen abstand reicht
das sind weiterhin egal ob er über
masten pflicht drehen oder nicht das
sind weiterhin die wichtigsten punkte
die wir ein behalten sollten also
abstand halten händewaschen niesen
husten etikette die masken pflicht ist
eine zusätzliche schutz weil auch gerade
durch die lockerung wäre wieder mehr
menschen zu lassen die sich im raum
bewegen um möglicherweise eben den
abstand nicht optimal einhalten können
und dabei eben immer noch nicht genau
wissen wie die dunkelziffer aussieht ist
es ein zusätzlicher schutz wenn jemand
doch infiziert sein sollte das eben
nicht
während werde in die umwelt gebracht
werden weil aufgrund wie gesagt der
lockerung vielleicht im die räumliche
enge etwas größer geworden ist aber
wichtiger punkt dass die
hygienemaßnahmen trotzdem eingehalten
werden
auf jeden fall auf jeden fall ein post
auf facebook der inzwischen knapp 40.000
mal geteilt worden es stammt von
wolfgang als er richtet sich vor allem
gegen den chef des robert koch instituts
also gegen professor lothar wieler und
calls schreibt auf diesem posten besser
gesagt darin so ihr vögel aus berlin
jetzt ist schluss mit lustig genau und
bevor ich jetzt hier alles weiter vor
lese höre ich gerade das gucken uns
jetzt nochmal an in einer maxi das ganze
nämlich noch viel schöner außen also in
einem beitrag und wir sprechen dann
darüber gleich
so ihr vögel aus berlin jetzt ist
schluss mit lustig 38.000 mal wurde
dieser post eines facebook users vom 15
april inzwischen geteilt
er richtet sich vor allem gegen den chef
des robert koch instituts am schlimmsten
ist da der wir gehen davon aus virologe
wieder vom robert koch institut
es steht fest dass die todesfall quote
etwa bei 0,37 prozent liegt sie her ich
gehe davon aus wir haben uns eine zehn
prozent quote eingeredet jede influenza
auf der ganzen welt ist bisher
dramatischer verlaufen als dieser corona
virus in schweden ist fast alles offen
und die quote ist nicht unwesentlich
höher als bei uns komisch oder
abschließend erwarte ich dass hier so
schnell wie möglich alles auf 100
prozent hochgefahren wird damit weitere
schlimme wirtschaftliche schäden
vermieden werden tja also herr doktor
stürmer da ist einiges drin gewesen
einige aussagen die natürlich
sprengstoff beinhalten gehen wir mal
zusammen run schweden wird genannt dass
es gilt ja sowieso oft als das
paradebeispiel dafür wie man mit diesem
virus vermeintlich unaufgeregter umgehen
kann mit gleichem erfolg aber die frage
ist ja tatsächlich ist der erfolg in
schweden auch der gleiche wie bei uns es
ist sicherlich erst mal eine ganz andere
herangehensweise und man darf nicht
glauben was in schweden alles erlaubt
ist das ist nicht der fall natürlich den
schweden restaurants cafés weiterhin
geöffnet aber insgesamt ist auch an die
bevölkerung die maßnahmen herangetragen
worden
sich möglichst zurückzuhalten was in der
öffentlichkeit was die öffentlichkeit
präsenz angeht und viele schweden halten
sich auch daran
auf der anderen seite muss man sehen
dass es auch sehr viele kritische
stimmen in schweden gibt viele
wissenschaftler sind überhaupt nicht
einverstanden mit der art und weise wie
schweden mit der situation umgeht und
sie führen auch gerne die die doch sehr
hohe todesfall rate an wenn man sich
anguckt dann ist sie 100.000 einwohner
die höchste in ganz skandinavischen raum
und insofern kann dort auch nicht alles
so gut gehen wie es gerne in diesem post
behauptet wird sondern auch die schweden
haben ihre probleme auch die schweden
haben eine hohe todesrate
und dementsprechend gibt es eben auch da
sehr viele kritische stimmen
vielleicht auch gerade da nochmal die
nachfrage david 8 stein auch auf youtube
geht in diese richtung ist das dann der
versuch der in schweden gemacht wird
eine herdenimmunität zu erreichen
ja das gibt geht sicherlich in die
richtung indem man eben einfach mehr
kontakte zulässt generiert man mehr
infektionen auf der anderen seite wenn
ich mir die zahlen anguckt sind wir mit
ich glaube inzwischen 15 oder 16 1000
infizierten leben noch weit weg von
einer ehren immunität insofern läuft es
auch da relativ langsam die infektion
was das angeht also auch da erkennt man
letztendlich das entweder in schweden
sehr wenig getestet wird oder eben das
eben halt auch die maßnahmen die dort im
hintergrund laufen die für uns
vielleicht gar nicht so präsent sind
weil sie anders kommuniziert werden denn
doch dafür sorgen dass eben nicht so
viele infiziert werden wie es ohne
maßnahmen ohne kontakt verbots
empfehlungen sein würde
ein anderer oft genannter punkt ist der
vergleich zum influenza virus das
angeblich ja noch gefährlicher sei und
deswegen sei eben die aufmerksamkeit für
das aktuelle corona virus zu groß ist
diese vergleichbarkeit gegeben wie
beurteilen sie das
nein man man macht es natürlich immer
gerne und das ist eigentlich auch
nachvollziehbar natürlich weiß ich bei
beiden um eine erkältungskrankheit
handelt und die influenza begleitet uns
schon viele jahre wir können ins gegen
influenza impfen lassen wir haben
medikamente die bei schweren verläufen
helfen können den zu mildern
und wenn wir uns jetzt einfach mal ganz
einfach die zahlen dieser die
diesjährigen grippewelle angucken wie
einst robert koch institut gemeldet wird
und ins detail gehen zu wollen liegt die
todesrate bei 0,24 prozent und damit
niedriger als das was in diesem facebook
post als zahl benannt worden ist und ich
glaube diese 0,35 ist da aus dieser 1
berg studie abgegriffen worden wo ja
auch realistisch sein wissen dass wir da
auch noch nicht wissen ob das der kehre
ich da weit ist insofern die die serie
grippe so sorgen die ich deutlich tiefer
als das was wir im augenblick für für
saas kaufte zwei sehen
und insofern ist der vergleich auch
nicht korrekt und man muss noch dazu
sagen
wir befinden uns was koch 2 angeht
erstens an beginn einer pandemie und
befinden uns in einer situation wo durch
möglich beispiellose maßnahmen der der
kontaktsperre wieder seit jahrzehnten so
nicht gehabt haben eine virus
verbreitung eingedämmt worden ist wenn
wir diese ungehindert hätten laufen
lassen dann bin ich mir sehr sicher dass
wir über ganz andere fallzahlen und ganz
andere todesfall rat sprechen würden und
die liegen dann deutlich höher als das
was im aktuellen situation weil er für
ein fans erkennen ja über die
sterblichkeit auch bei den corona fühlen
würde ich gerne noch mit ihnen sprechen
gleich zunächst noch die frage von
sascha auf twitter könnte das virus aus
einem labor stammen spannende frage wird
momentan auch viel diskutiert es gibt ja
verschiedene theorien die eine ist dass
es tatsächlich eine züchtung im labor
ist das ist er aus einem fall aus den
folgen grund unwahrscheinlich weil der
weg den unser saas koch 2 gegangen ist
um sich an den menschen zu adaptieren
scheint nicht der zu sein indem er zum
beispiel vom alten saß corona virus
erkennen auch das war gut an den
menschen adaptiert und der saß kopf 2
ist ein anderer weg wenn ich jetzt
wissenschaftler im labor wäre und ich
sollte es ein virus manipulieren würde
ich mich an eine vorlage der vorlage
nehmen die schon habe und würde an der
um arbeiten und das ist wohl nicht der
fall
die zweite theorie die es ja gab dass es
eben dieses eine hochsicherheitslabor
ingo hahn gibt wo an fledermäusen
gearbeitet wird dass da eben durch
fehler im umgang mit der sicherheit das
virus nach draußen oder einen virus aus
den fledermäusen nach draußen gebracht
worden ist auch hierzu ist zu sagen dass
die fledermäuse das denen ein bestimmter
in einem bestimmten gen bereich eine
mutation fehlt die wir in den
menschlichen isolaten alle sehen da
fehlt also irgendwo ein ein übergang
wenn ich es direkt von der fledermaus
auf den menschen hätte bekommen müssen
dann hätte ich zumindest in einigen
menschen diese wie
in variante finden müssen aber die
finden wir nicht insofern ist es auch
das eher wahrscheinlicher dass es doch
auf einen zwischen wird übergegangen ist
und von dem zwischen wird auf den
menschen oder aber eben sich evolutionär
auf natürlichem wege in uns menschen
entwickelt hat kommen wir noch mal auf
die sterblichkeit zu sprechen die ist
glücklicherweise zumindest in
deutschland relativ gering wir haben
übrigens anders als das vorhin auf
facebook eben dargestellt worden ist
keine horrorszenarien von 10% gefunden
also aussagen in dieser richtung die
herr wieder getätigt haben soll
wie haben sie das beobachtet hat das rk
ii haben andere stellen am anfang da ein
zu düsteres bild gezeichnet war das
fahrlässig habe dass panik geschürt die
so nicht hätte sein sollen
also ich kann auch diese zählt prozent
nicht nachvollziehen das sind die zahlen
die wir eher aus italien oder irgendwo
kennen für deutschland gab es die nie
und wohl noch nie kommuniziert und nein
in der kommunikation glaube ich ist es
eher wichtig am anfang etwas zu
pessimistisch zu sein oder zu vorsichtig
zu sein weil im nachhinein ist natürlich
immer klüger ich kann dazu ein beispiel
aus der schweinegrippezeit berichten
auch dort wurde ja die pandemie
ausgerufen weil die ersten signale sehr
alarmierend waren im nachhinein wurde
man dafür belächelt aber ich sage immer
was wir anders herum gewesen man macht
das nicht man verharmlost das ganze und
es gibt eben doch einen schweren
ausbruch mit vielen erkrankten und
vielen toten
dann heißt es hinterher auch warum habt
ihr nicht gleich gesagt dass das so
schlimm ist ich denke dass der weg der
gegangen worden ist der richtige ist
wenn wir uns im nachhinein darüber
unterhalten werden dass das ganze etwas
zu alt oder zu rigide war umso besser
aber dann haben wir wenigstens nicht
hinterher
viele viele menschen zu beklagen wie
verstorben sind und was wir hätten
verhindern können
sonja sauer fragt über youtube hätten
sie für die pandemie einen alternativen
lösungsvorschlag als das warten auf
einen impfstoff tatsächlich nicht ich
denke dass das der weg sein wird wie wir
mehr oder weniger dann zu einer
normalität zurückkehren werden man muss
natürlich abwarten wie dieser impfstoff
oder wie lang die immunität anhalten
die wir durch diesen impfstoff bekommen
auch das sind ja noch ungeklärte fragen
habt ihr auch vielfach in der diskussion
wie lange hält jetzt auch mein
immunschutz an wann kann ich mich mit
dem virus wieder weg infizieren ist das
nach monaten nach jahren nach
jahrzehnten der fall und das sind
natürlich noch ungeklärte fragen
und dann müssen wir noch ein bisschen
warten dass wir diese antwort geben
können aber eins ist meiner meinung nach
ganz sicher ohne den impfstoff wird es
einen weg zur normalität nicht geben
ich komme noch mal kurz auf den facebook
kritiker zu sprechen da wird ja auch
generell aber das wird nicht nur von ihm
so gemacht die sprachliche sagen wir mal
unschärfe kritisiert des
robert-koch-instituts dass es also oft
heißt wir gehen davon aus dass ist
dieser vorwurf berechtigt oder muss die
wissenschaft viel mehr so in einer
frühen phase dieses dieser pandemie noch
so vage bleiben
das ist absolut wichtig weil wir können
im prinzip eigentlich nur rückschlüsse
ziehen auch das verhalten dieses virus
was wir jetzt seit knapp dreieinhalb
monaten erst kennen indem der analogen
ziehen zu anderen viren
es gibt ja viele coronaviren nicht nur
das alte sars virus wir haben auch
andere romane coronaviren die uns seit
jahren und jahrzehnten schon begleiten
und dann versucht man eben rückschlüsse
daraus zu ziehen sofern es absolut
berechtigt auch nicht den eindruck zu
vermitteln dass wir alles schon wissen
über dieses virus sondern dass man eben
alles genau auch klar macht mit diesen
formulierungen
das ist der aktuelle kenntnisstand den
wir haben mehr können wir dazu nicht
sagen und es kann gut sein dass das was
wir heute erzählen in einer woche
vielleicht gar nicht mehr in dieser form
stimmt das wissen wir einfach nicht und
damit müssen wir auch als experten leben
und unsere lernkurve ist ebenso hoch wie
der politiker und und art von uns allen
wir müssen noch mal kurz über die
herdenimmunität sprechen herr stürmer es
wird viel von einem impfstoff geredet
schreibt kühn auf youtube der aber wohl
erst habe es gerade auch noch mal gesagt
in einem jahr frühestens zur verfügung
stehen wird auf basis der heutigen
zahlen wie hoch schätzt man die
herdenimmunität in einem jahr ein
gute frage wie gesagt wenn wir das level
halten und vielleicht sogar eigentlich
aber ist ja unser ziel dass das
level an neuinfektionen pro tag noch
weiter nach unten geht dann werden wir
selbst eine dunkelziffer von von 10
fachen annehmen werden wir jetzt bei
etwas mehr als anderthalb millionen
und wenn wir die neuinfektionen relativ
gering halten dann sind wir in einem
jahr bei lassen sie es jetzt musste ich
herstellen kopf rechnet beim millionen
sein aber wir werden diese 50 millionen
in dieser jetzigen situation nicht
erreichen und ist es wahrscheinlich dann
aber auch nicht notwendig andersrum wenn
die frage da erzählt warum machen wir
nicht einfach auf und lassen das ganze
durchlaufen um die mobilität eben
schneller zu bekommen bevor der
impfstoff da ist da kann man wirklich
nur vorwarnen weil das würde im prinzip
innerhalb kürzester zeit unser
gesundheitssystem zum überlaufen bringen
und uns vor situation stellen die welt
italien gesehen haben dass die ärzte
entscheiden müssen wer wird behandelt
werde kommen da im intensivbetten wäre
nicht ja das ist die berüchtigte triage
die wollen wir natürlich nicht haben in
deutschland gregor schulte fragt über
youtube die dunkelziffer ist die
entscheidende unbekannte wenn die
schwedischen annahmen stimmen liegt sie
bei faktor 200 behauptet er jetzt laut
universität oxford bei faktor 400 in
deutschland geht man von faktor 5 aus
kann das so stimmen ja wenn wir uns
jetzt mal die heinsberg studie wieder
vor augen führen ungeachtet der kritik
auf die 15 prozent die dort gefunden
worden
tatsächlich realistische heinsberg war
eine oder ist eine hochburg der
infektion gewesen und dementsprechend
haben wir da 15 jetzt gemessen in einem
einer repräsentativen studie mit
antikörpertest und 15 prozent sind noch
immer weit weg von den 60 ich denke dass
die 15 zu hoch sind und denke auch er
dass wir deutlich niedriger liegen und
insofern hat sich die frage damit auch
geklärt auch das wäre ein faktor 4 100
oder 200 haben dass das halte ich für
absurd
dabei gezogen vielleicht noch mal zum
abschluss die frage an sie sie waren
eben auch betroffen von der krankheit
kennen sich aber auch beruflich bedingt
bestens aus wie empfinden sie den umgang
deutschlands mit der korona krise
übertreiben wir oder wo sehen sie
vielleicht verbesserungsbedarf nein
übertreiben tun war sicherlich nicht was
ich ein bisschen immer schade finde ist
dass wir bei allen vorteilen unser
föderales system hat gerade jetzt in der
situation wie wir sie mit den
lockerungen er erleben doch ein
ziemliches durcheinander produzieren das
war am anfang mit den maßnahmen genau
das gleiche in dem ein bundesland war
das erlaubt in dem anderen das und ich
glaube da wieder ein bisschen mehr
einheit deutlich deutlich besser sein
nur zur nachvollziehbarkeit sowohl für
uns bürger im lande als natürlich in der
wahrnehmung von außen her und ich glaube
das ist sicherlich etwas wo man arbeiten
kann
und ansonsten bin ich aber der meinung
dass die die vorgabe die maßgaben die
getätigt worden sind absolut adäquat
gewesen sind die befürworter des
föderalen systems sagen natürlich dann
man kann dann besser reagieren auch auf
regionale unterschiede
das ist absolut richtig das ist ja auch
mein argument für den föderalismus auf
der anderen seite sind wir eine
situation wo es vielleicht auch sinnvoll
ist da ein bisschen ein bisschen
struktur reinzubringen und und einheit
zu schaffen und bestimmte dinge eben
einfach auch zu sagen dass das da halten
wir uns alle daran weil ich ja schon so
ein bisschen die befürchtung habe dass
das vorpreschen auf der einen oder
anderen seite gerade was in den
lockerungen diskutiert wird dort
vielleicht ein bisschen noch zu vieles
wir sind noch nicht in einer situation
wo wir sehr sicher sein können dass
lockerungsmaßnahmen kein schaden
anrichten werden sondern wir sind auf
einem fragilen situation
und wenn man jetzt zu viel will und in
einigen bundesländern vielleicht auch
schon zu viel macht dann kann uns das
auf neudeutsch auch noch mal um die
ohren fliegen was wir vermeiden sollten
dann nehme ich das mal so als schluss
vor dr martin stürmer war dass er ist
biologe aus frankfurt und lehrt unter
anderem dort auch an der
johann-wolfgang-goethe-universität
vielen dank für dieses sehr interessante
gesprächen schönen abend noch sehr gerne
ebenfalls und auch euch vielen dank für
das interesse und natürlich auch für
eure fragen nicht vergessen möchte ich
darauf hinzuweisen dass ist die
überarbeitete zdf heute app gibt da
könnte ja auch noch mal vieles rund um
das thema corona nachlesen aber
natürlich auch zu allen möglichen
anderen themen vielen dank für euer
interesse und einen schönen abend
bis bald
[Musik]